I don't know about you guys I might be a
little older than some of you but for me
the iMac was such a revolutionary device
because it was something that not only
changed the trajectory of Apple but it
also changed the way that consumers
thought about technology it made them
approachable it made them fun and it
gave us the choice of colors and when I
think back to that time it was such a
turning point for me but also Apple in
general so the fact that we have these
amazing throwback cases that span has
done yet again some of you may remember
iPhone 10 here it is 5 years ago I
unboxed some of these cases and now here
we are back again with a refreshed
version that will fit your iPhone 15 Pro
or Pro Max this has taken it to a whole
another level like it actually looks
like that's like 3D like when I look at
this I don't know if you guys can tell
does kind of look like it has like
different layers like it really does
have the feel of the iMac and they're
magsafe compatible we love to see it
click my link in the bio to get one
today